le mont blanc en france perd un peu plus
chaque année de sa majestuosité
skieurs et alpiniste le constate le
glacier a reculé de près d'un kilomètre
l'épaisseur de la mer de glace a diminué
d'environ 200 m depuis 50 ans
au pied de la montagne on se creuse les
méninges pour freiner la fonte mais
aussi pour diversifier le tourisme parce
que la neige se fera de plus en plus
rares
le québec non plus n'est pas épargné par
les changements climatiques prenez par
exemple ce cocktail météo de la fin du
mois d'avril qui empêche la prolongation
de la saison de ski dans plusieurs
régions se pose la question comment
maximiser l'utilisation de la montagne
et les retombées économiques
ici par exemple au mont grand-fonds dans
charlevoix ont misé sur la randonnée
pédestre
c'est vraiment une volonté de développer
le 4 saisons pour le directeur de
tourisme charlevoix la vitalité de la
région en dépend ça vient renforcer le
lien aussi avec les commerçants locaux
donc des partenariats plus à l'année
qu'on peut faire puis bref c'est toute
la vie économique qui bénéficie d'un
virage quatre saisons la majorité de nos
montagnes au québec sont développées
autour d'une seule activité on pense
tout de suite au ski alpin mais on ne
peut plus tout misé sur le ce qu'il
pense la ministre caroline proulx qui
invite neuf régions à lui soumettre un
plan montagne quatre saisons financé à
hauteur de 11 millions de dollars une
étude du consortium ouranos a conclu que
d'ici 2050 l'industrie touristique situé
proche du fleuve connaîtra plus de
difficultés avec les précipitations de
pluie ça pourrait être développée du
arbre en arbre du côté de l'esprit dans
les stations ça peut être de construire
des pôles d'observation et en plus on
vient répondre à un enjeu de main
d'oeuvre parce qu'on est capable
d'attaché donc des gens sur quatre
saisons
novembre décembre c'est mort ça commence
un petit peu la main vers la fête des
patriotes
se paie de gestion personnelle qui est
assez long pour garder ses employés la
propriétaire de cette boulangerie de la
malbaie souhaite plus de touristes au
printemps et à l'automne encore faut-il
avoir le personnel pour gérer tout ça
l'année vient contredire un peu ce que
j'ai dit en fait pour qu'un plan
montagne quatre saisons fonctionne il ne
faire aucun doute pour elle qu'il faudra
aussi un plan pour contrer la pénurie
demandeurs ici véronique prince radio
canada québec